hey what's up everybody at cinematic and
welcome to a brand new series here on
our YouTube channel from now on every
Sunday we're going to be uploading a
roundup of the best anime videos of the
week before in our opinion and basically
the purpose of these videos is going to
be to give you guys a chance to catch up
on some of the awesome anime videos you
might have missed and also will give us
a chance to give you some commentary and
feedback on our favorite anime videos
now obviously we won't be able to watch
every single enemy video that comes out
at any given week but if you guys want
to recommend a specific video to us you
can just comment in the previous week's
video so for example if you want to give
us a recognition for next week just
comment in this video or you can contact
us on social media which we check pretty
much every day so yeah we hope you guys
enjoyed this series and now let's get
right to the videos on Wednesday
TeamFourStar uploaded episode 55 of
their dragon ball z abridged series and
we waited a while for this one but it
was definitely worth it we got to see
some mr. popo being a total badass
moments we got to see chichi being way
too aggressive like super freak
aggressive moments if you know what I
mean and yeah definitely worth the wait
and if you're one of those people who
just likes to complain about when the
next episode is coming out you can
officially start complaining about
episode 56 right now now noble AK lost
pause was actually in Japan earlier this
week and he made some pretty cool videos
along with Joey AK the anime man about
his experiences in Japan vlogging and
things like that yeah they were just
goofing around making a lot of funny
stuff they did a try not to laugh
challenge where they both failed
miserably as we all know they would so
yeah it was pretty fun if you're a fan
of those guys definitely check those
videos out now noble actually came back
from Japan last week and on Friday he
uploaded a video about his impressions
of Japan kind of the cultural
differences between Japan and North
America so it was definitely an
interesting watch I gotta really give it
to noble if I was visiting Japan I
wouldn't be uploading videos everyday
like he did I mean I've seen him I think
I pulled three videos a day on certain
days so you know you really gotta
respect his commitment that guy deserves
every single subscriber he has and yeah
keep it up man now Wednesday was
actually also Joey the anime man's
birthday so he uploaded on interest
video where he basically invited his
fans to roast him in the video and he
was reading their comments and yeah I
was pretty fun it was pretty
entertaining so that's something you
might want to check out if you're Joey
fan there was also a lot of unboxing
going on this week Joey you had an
unboxing video on Thursday aki diras had
a 2 unboxing videos including one when
she came back right after she came back
from the dentist so she couldn't really
talk and like she actually had to put
subtitles in her own video so we knew
what she was saying I think it was
pretty cute it was pretty funny and on
Friday noble actually also did a
unboxing videos so so much box this week
guys so much box now Joey the anime man
actually has a second channel called
Joey I know real original right and this
week he uploaded a vlog where he visited
a small japanese village called yahiko
and i really like the vlog and it got me
thinking i know a lot of people want to
go to japan to see Tokyo and all those
bright lights of the city but to me I
feel like I want to go to a small
village and just enjoy the nature and be
kind of like ginkgo from mushishi like I
don't know if I'm the only one is anyone
else with me on this one anyone now if
you're a fan of sports anime this week
digi bro uploaded a really cool
comparative analysis of two anime high Q
which is a volleyball anime and kuroko
no basket which is a basketball anime
and he really went into great detail
comparing them the protagonist that
styles of the anime the genre of Sports
anime in general so if you're a fan
definitely check that out and also in
the world of digi bro on Friday he
uploaded a review of mob psycho 100
where he compared that anime with one
punch man and I thought that was also
really insightful so yeah digi bros
channel is definitely a great place to
go for some good analysis now on
saturday aki dearest uploaded her
monthly otaku favorites video where she
talks about some of her favorite anime
otaku related content of the month
before in this video she talked about
our easy row she talked about 91 days d
anime and she also talked about the
final fantasy app i think it's called
brave XX vs or something like that so
yeah interesting video definitely liked
her feedback like to hear what you
thought on those things and yeah check
it out soul animation uploaded a river
you of fairy tail manga chapters five
hundred to five hundred and three this
week and you can really tell that this
guy loves fairy tale that he knows his
stuff so if you're a big fairy tale fan
definitely check out soul animations
content now misti crane nexia or as he
likes to say misty / crow nexia uploaded
a new top 10 list this friday and this
time it was top 10 funniest anime ever
and yeah if you're looking for some last
it's definitely a good list check it out
and apparently misty is considering
redoing some of his older top 10 lists
now that he's seen a lot more anime and
things like that so you know I'm
definitely fine with that as long as the
number one position on every list goes
to clannad take that misty whoa you also
might have seen a whole bunch of videos
this week talking about Dragon Ball
super and black go whose true identity
and unfortunately a whole bunch of
videos seem to have spoilers right there
in the title so if you didn't want
spoilers you were kind of screwed but I
did find a video by my star media that
did a good job of warning about spoilers
and it was a quick video talked about
his theory about Black Oak whose
identity so definitely check that out if
that's something you're interested in
and finally if you've been following
that whole YouTube heroes drama from two
weeks ago last Sunday we actually
uploaded our latest comedy skit where we
made fun of that whole mess so that's
something you're interested in
definitely check it out and yeah we hope
you guys enjoyed this video we hope
you're gonna like this series and until
next time see you space cowboys